would say you eat food
i don't think so today we're finding out
how different food is made and we'll
discover will we still eat it
starting off with how pringles is made i
actually really want to know this
because
how obviously
how they make the pringle called whoop
huh
huh i guess we're gonna find out these
tubes are ideal containers
for stackable chips the foil will help
keep the chips fresh
wait what is this the streams of paper
travel across rollers that coat them
with glue
do you say blue the paper layers twist
around a mandrel
that's turned by a big belt i see no
problem in it also presses
the glued layers together oh glue okay
oh they're they're making the packages
gets a coat of glue well i don't care no
no no
no no no they're trying to stall us
they're trying to hide their
pringles secrets as much as possible
yeah well i can click ahead of the video
of one third water a conveyor delivers
the mixture there's a potato disperses
it
nice oh okay it falls between
i'm not gonna lie i kinda wanna do a
little bit
come on don't tell me you don't want to
do that why can't i
suck my finger but not my microphone and
without getting demonetized
life is not fair using four tons of
pressure they roll the mix
into one long potato sheet damn
giant potato that's the mr peas video
right there
i made the biggest pringle let's go
the potato sheet goes under a rotary
cutter that punches out oval shapes
oh well that makes sense
a device pulls away the scrap dough
leaving flat
uncooked chips seems like a lot of waste
this scrap potato dough goes back into
the chip making operation
while the potato chips head into a fryer
that's amazing
there they go look at them hell yeah all
right here we go
through the fryer rolling molds make
them concave
okay the concave shape will make the
chips stackable
did you see that how pringle
no no you can't do that the concave
shape will make
you can't just oh they teleported with a
magic pringle spell
how does that happen you can't just edit
a how did the pringle get on the pringle
convey her things
make them concave the concave shape will
make
i'm so pissed off
no no no all right i'm i'm all for the
pringles sparsity
prick kring seriously pringles aren't
real clearly
because they're editing it out how do
they get how do they get there
how do they get there you got dough it's
all smooshy
you can't just get that there that
doesn't work i don't believe this
machinery now i don't believe anything
the concave shape will make the chips
stackable
oh they got each one that's kind of cute
see they're back to fly the chips spend
11 seconds frying in hot oil this makes
them crispy
how how how they travel under blowers
to get rid of excess oil see they're
trying they're trying to distract us now
at this point
the chips get a coat of seasoning then
do a backflip
off one conveyor and onto another do you
say they do a backflip
that's amazing
i can't even do a backflip all right
pringles are cool i'll still eat them
they do a backflip hell yeah oh no
the worker inspects the rows of chips
[Music]
that one's bad that one's coming
i want that job i really do then
it's on to another conveyor that shakes
them up to loosen the pack
oh what why yeah they were tucked so
neatly
why would you shake them i don't want
shaken pringles
back flip only no shake please they
travel over scales
to portion them out for packaging
automated spoons
shove the chips into the open ends of
the tubes well
i don't know man no pringles aren't real
i will never eat a pringle again they're
made with a spell that teleports them
which makes them curvy great thanks for
answering nothing
the next one i want to check out is how
sausages is made
because every time you eat a sausage
someone goes
if you knew if you knew how that was
made you wouldn't eat it oh yeah
well today i'm gonna be that guy all
right oh this looks delicious let's
click on that
hell yeah the cuts they start with are
called trimmings
nice meat left over from cutting steaks
or pork chops mmm they're good stuff
want to do this give me that
oh that looks satisfying the trimmings
are ground the same way butchers chop yo
it's santa claus right there
santa is making all the sausages i can't
believe it hamburger meat
by pushing the cuts through grated metal
plates
yeah that looks like hell
why is it so great processed chicken
trimmings are added to the ground
followed by food starch salt
and other flavorings okay
i know it's people in different regions
have different tastes a lot of quantity
but
seeing it like that looks insane
oh man you spilt like half of it fire
that dude i can do way better job
what is that look at that into the mix
and everything is blended together
oh now we get the goo nice hell yeah
give me that goop i wanna eat that goat
corn syrup adds a dash of sweetness mmm
a little dash eh
[ __ ] waterfall okay now we got some
color all this focus of the seasoning
right
no it's still dead dude that looks
straight out of a horror movie
you cannot convince me otherwise that
looks like when the
when the demon transforms into its third
form or something of even more water
helps to disperse the ingredients
and make the hot dogs juicier mmm so
juicy
machine then purees the
i've seen meat image before i have not
that was a joke
long rolls of cellulose tubing are
loaded into the stuffing machine
cellulite cellulose oh it's a pack okay
got it
it pumps the meat puree into these
twisting it every five
and a quarter inches the length of one
hot dog this woman knows how to handle
sausages it's just 35 seconds to make a
chain of hot dogs
that would span a soccer field twice
hell yeah so fast
it's kind of cool what just watch
honestly so that a twist
always lands on the bar the wrap
shunt the hot dogs have a shower smoke
shower then into an oven with several
cooking zones
all right the liquid smoke seeps through
the casing and adds flavor to the dogs
as they bake
i didn't know i thought marsha was
trolling me i didn't know liquid smoke
is a thing it's a flavoring that makes
it taste smoky but it's liquid
how how can smoke be liquid alright
maybe hot dog isn't really either i
don't know
hell yeah toasty boys let's go all right
now it looks
more appealing these franks are drenched
in cold salty water to chill them in
preparation for packaging
uh-huh hot dog army assembled dogs then
file down to when they're coming to take
over the world
the absence of a black stripe means the
hot dog is cooked
and ready for packaging oh so
they're not cooked yet what
inside the peeler machine a tiny knife
slits each casing along the top
then steamy air blows the casings right
off the dogs
i feel like there's a weird sex joke you
know i don't
know if i want to do it there they go
an inspector makes sure the casing has
been completely removed
whoa and that there are no defects in
the dogs damn she's just like a
sausage wizard that one
you want that's amazing then it's into a
device that looks like a plastic bicycle
chain
the sprockets positions
okay all right okay cool
yeah i'll still eat the hot dog i don't
care i mean i don't i mean i am
pescetarian so i don't of course but
fake hot dog yes
it didn't really gross me out that much
as i thought even though i mean
okay yeah the goo was pretty gross yeah
what the [ __ ] what am i saying i want
more meat ones
all right bacon i got some beatboxing
bacon is now priced
and baked pre-cooked in factories
[Music]
hell yeah it all starts with a load of
pork bellies damn
they're tossed into a big tumbler the
bellies go into
another belly eh that's hilarious the
action softens them
so it will be easier to remove the skins
ew
i didn't know that for some reason
it's a lot more manual labor to make
bacony this conveyor takes the pork
bellies to a long automated blade
that slices the skin away from the meat
okay
the skins drop onto another conveyor
belt processed into pork rinds
pork rinds yeah i mean the skin is the
tastiest part but
you're eating skin bro the meat pieces
head toward a flipping device
that turns them backside up so workers
down the line can trim off any remaining
pieces of skin
bacon bacons also do a backflip before
they get eaten
i appreciate that next
they mix up the insulation which will
cure the pork
salt is funneled into a tank of water
just a dash of salt
that's all it needs really it's mixed
thoroughly until the salt dissolves
hell yeah enough to kill a man right
away then
liquid smoke and other flavorings are
added
what's [ __ ] it's not real smoke
what is liquid smoke i need to know that
you can't just liquefy smoke
it's molasses vinegar caramel color and
salt
what chips and sawdust excuse me
you're eating sawdust that's needles
marinated into each pork belly let's go
stab that [ __ ]
a metal hanger called a comb is pressed
into each of the pork bellies i've seen
they can be hung on a rack
dude he was having a time where his life
doing those
like hell yeah this is hilarious it's
into the drench cabinet
for a shower of liquid smoke more liquid
smoke
or maybe there's many yeah it adds
flavor and color to the surface
that's what makes it so red huh
it doesn't it's not actually that fresh
it's just like transferred to a big oven
they'll cook for five hours at a low
temperature
that allows the flavoring to permeate
the meat
dude they cook in there and people walk
inside that would terrify me
i would not want to walk in there here
workers load the meat slabs into shoots
hell yeah they do a little dance a
little tickle
before they go back and forth over a
blade which slices them
that's kind of funky
[Laughter]
the bacon falls neatly onto a conveyor
belt oh man
let's go the fat cooks off the bacon it
drains into a trough
okay all right i think i get it that's
kind of nasty not gonna lie
i mean obviously they don't even show
the process of cutting off the belly
which i think would turn me off
completely i mean i don't eat me but
whatever it's stupid
i'm kind of curious how they make like
uh fake meat then
because i know it's it's just soy or
mushroom or something
and i wonder if it's like freaky or
something the first thing i wanted to
know
was what actually went into the burger
yeah this is soy beans
and the soybeans have been kind of
texturized
and this gives you the high protein
content and the nice
chew and texture of meat nice less fat
high protein won't clog up your heart
not give you high blood pressure heart
attacks you know
so this is the impossible burger i've
had it it's really good
but i can't digest it every time i eat
the impossible burger i feel like [ __ ]
that's beat right that's how they can do
this refer to impossible as the burger
that
bleeds but what people are actually
talking about isn't blood
but heme which is by all accounts the
most important part of the impossible
burn that one
this is the section we're in the heme
section how we produce the heme is that
we use fermentation
so they use some sort of fermentation
process to make the red goo
okay people don't choose to eat burgers
because they are healthy anyway so who
cares if they're healthy or not i think
they should
why not so it's not healthier just
environmental friendly
huh okay interesting i feel like i
learned something here today pringles
isn't real and that's it if you want
more videos
subscribe smash like and i'll see you
bros tomorrow brofist
you thought it was gay but true
relevance
never really died welcome to the first
undead game use any item in your
inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there
stickers our emotions memes our emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
circle baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this